Salmon's a real big hit in our household
over Christmas it's delicious so
versatile and tastes absolutely amazing
now we're going to do a delicious salmon
nissis which is a really nice way of
reinvigorating your taste buds across
Christmas first of all we're going to
poach this in a really nice fragrant C
Bion C buleon is just a fancy name for
poaching liquor first add fennel with
its lovely anit flavor to
water then put in chopped celery onions
and
salt next pour in some white wine to
give it some
body add a splash of Tagan vinegar to
give it bite that wakes up everything
that really makes it sort of slightly
acidic but more importantly goes
brilliantly well with the salmon to add
flavor pop in a couple of staranise and
Crush white pepper
corns for freshness and Zing put in a
handful of parsley a couple of bay
leaves and a sliced
lemon then bring the liquid up to the
boil and slip in the
salmon no need to season it cuz the
water called buong is all seasoned
beautifully slip that in nice and gently
skin side
down Salmon's sweet delicate and
Incredibly flavorsome now it's going to
go even higher in terms of flavor simmer
the salmon for 4 to 5 minutes then turn
it off and let it cool down in the
liquid after 10 minutes take the turkey
out of the oven and baste then cover the
breasts with smoked streaky BAC
what I want to do is add a little bit
more flavor turkey is a very very very
lean bird and it dries out so it's so
important to make sure that we help it
to cook perfectly